Saving Basketball
On a cold, late November Wednesday in Minneapolis,
Minnesota, a crowd of 7,021 arrived to the
Minneapolis Auditorium to watch an NBA game
between the Fort Wayne Pistons and the Minneapolis
Lakers.
This was a new experience for many of the
fans in the stands.
The NBA had formed due to a merger between
rival leagues, the Basketball Association
of America (BAA) and the National Basketball
League (NBL), less than 16 months before.
The new league was still trying to find its
footing.
Each game represented a chance to win – and
lose – fans.
This matchup boasted some of the brightest
basketball stars of the day – most prominent
of all, the great George Mikan.
A basketball prodigy since his college days
at DePaul in Chicago, he joined the Lakers
in 1947 and dominated games right from the
start.
At six foot ten, Mikan’s rebounding, shot
blocking, and killer hook shoot elevated him
to becoming the signature player of the new
NBA.
Along with Mikan, six foot seven future Hall
of Famer Vern Mikkelsen and former Stanford
All-American Jim Pollard made the Minneapolis
Lakers one of the most feared teams in the
league.
The Fort Wayne Pistons did not match up in
talent to the Lakers and they knew it.
But the coach of the Pistons, and Indiana
Basketball Hall of Famer, Murray Mendenhall
had a plan.
The buzzer sounded, the clock began ticking,
and the opening tip went to the Fort Wayne
Pistons.
As Ralph Johnson, the Pistons’ point guard,
dribbled down court staring at the intimidating
behemoth defensive front court of Mikan and
friends, he was under direct orders from his
coach.
Those orders were to hold the ball.
Mendenhall’s philosophy for the game was
quite simple: If the Lakers never got the
ball, they could never score.
If they could never score, they could never
win the game.
As the seconds ticked by and the Pistons did
nothing but pass the ball back and forth between
one another, everyone not on the Pistons became
frustrated.
The Lakers players stood around, not knowing
what to do.
Occasionally they would foul simply to have
a chance to get the ball back.
The referees yelled at the Pistons players
and at coach Mendenhall to play ball.
Worst of all, the fans in the stands began
to boo and stomp their feet in anger.
At half-time, the score was 13 to 11 in favor
of the Lakers with Mikan scoring 12 of the
Lakers’ points.
This was the new league’s worst nightmare.
The second half was even worse.
The Lakers, despite being annoyed at the Pistons’
strategy, began to subscribe to the old adage
“if you can’t beat ‘em, join ‘em.”
Each team holding the ball for minutes at
a time; the two teams only scored 13 points
combined in the second half.
As the clock mercifully ticked down to zero
in the fourth quarter, the Pistons held a
one point lead, 19 to 18.
A missed Lakers’ shot at the buzzer gave
the Pistons the win, and upset, in the lowest
scoring game in NBA history.
Mikan was “held” to a game high 15 points.
Lakers coach John Kundla, disgusted, said
after the game, ““If that’s basketball,
I don’t want any part of it.”
Maurice Podoloff knew something had to be
done to make sure a game of this nature never
happened again.
He was the man who had been put in charge
to ensure the survival of the NBA and professional
basketball.
Podoloff was the former president of the BAA
and had negotiated the merger between the
BAA and the NBL to form the NBA.
He was the logical choice to become the NBA
president in 1949.
Podoloff knew the only way this league was
going to flourish was by making sure the game
was fun and exciting to the people who paid
his and the players’ salary – the fans.
“It seems to me that the teams showed complete
disregard for the interest of the fans by
the type of game they played,” said Podoloff
the next day.
On that Friday (two days after the game),
he summoned all league officials and the two
referees from the infamous game to figure
out ways to make the NBA game more fan-friendly.
They came up with several rule changes that
would be instituted in the coming year, including
the widening of the key from six feet to twelve
feet.
They thought these changes would increase
scoring and the blunt the impact of one dominant
player (in this case, George Mikan).
It didn’t work.
Scoring was still low, fewer fans came out
to the games, and teams began to fold.
By the end of the 1953-1954 season, the NBA
was down to nine teams.
Professional basketball was very much in trouble.
The owner of the Syracuse Nationals, Daniel
Biasone, may have not been the first person
to suggest a “shot clock,” but he was
the man who convinced the NBA to use it.
In 1946, Biasone paid five thousand dollars
to the NBL for his Syracuse Nationals to have
the right to play in the new professional
basketball league.
After some initial struggles, Biasone had
enough of losing and paid a young player by
the name of Dolph Schayes to come play in
Syracuse.
Schayes was considered by many to be the best
player in college while at NYU and surprised
many when he choose to play in upstate New
York instead of the Big Apple and the New
York Knicks.
Money was definitely a factor in Schayes’s
decision; Biasone had offered Schayes fifty
percent more than the Knicks.
Schayes also liked the smallness of Syracuse,
having been quoted as saying he liked the
“camaraderie of small town fans.”
Schayes was a hit in Syracuse and immediately
legitimized the fledgling team.
The Nationals were absorbed as part of the
merger and became an original NBA franchise
in 1949.
By 1954, the “Nats” were flat out good
with Schayes leading the way, finishing with
a 42-30 record and making it all the way to
the NBA Finals before losing to the Lakers
four games to three.
As the NBA and the Nationals entered the 1954-1955
season, there was fear that this may be professional
basketball’s last hurrah, exemplified by
The New York Times writing that “professional
basketball’s existence was in jeopardy.”
None of the rule changes meant to increase
scoring and make the game more fan-friendly
had worked.
But Biasone had an idea.
He had watched and studied hundreds of basketball
games since his Nats joined the league over
eight years ago.
After much thought, he determined that a “well-balanced”
game meant that each team took 60 shots a
game, or 120 total shots in a game.
Each game was 48 minutes, or 2880 seconds,
long.
Using basic math, Biasone divided 2880 seconds
by 120 shots and got a magic number – 24.
According to this formula, a well-balanced
game required a shot every 24 seconds.
Therefore, a clock counting down from 24 seconds
would force teams to shoot in this amount
of time or less, creating a much more exciting
and fun game.
Now, Biasone needed to convince Podoloff and
the rest of the NBA that his 24 second shot
clock would be solution to their scoring problem.
He experimented with it during National’s
exhibition games and it had the necessary
impact on scoring that the NBA adopted for
the 1954-1955 regular season.
On October 30th, 1954, in a game between the
Rochester Royals and the Boston Celtics, the
shot clock officially debuted.
It was a rousing success with the Royals defeating
the Celtics 98 to 95.
Daniel Biasone and his 24 second shot clock
had saved professional basketball.
The 1954-1955 season saw scoring jump by over
13 points a game from the previous season.
Along with scoring, fan excitement soared.
The Boston Celtics became the first NBA team
to average more than 100 points.
By 1959, every team was averaging more than
100 points per game.
NBA president Maurice Podoloff admitted that
this innovation rescued basketball,
The twenty-four-second rule has worked so
well that I firmly believe it has proved the
salvation of professional basketball.
So far this year attendance receipts at our
games have increased 57 percent…
The adoption of the clock (has been) most
important event in the NBA.
Today, a monument, an actual shot clock that
counts down from 24, stands in downtown Syracuse,
New York commemorating the impact Daniel Biasone
and his shot clock had in saving the game
of basketball.
Bonus Facts:
 George Mikan is considered to be the first
superstar of the NBA.
Nicknamed “Mr. Basketball,” he led his
teams to seven championships, won three scoring
titles, and was so dominant rules were named
after him, including the widening of the lane
from six to twelve feet — “the Mikan Rule.”
Always wearing his trademark thick round glasses,
he played eleven seasons and was voted in
1950 “The Greatest Basketball Player of
the First Half Century.”
He had a huge impact on the game even after
his retirement in 1956.
He was the first commissioner of the revolutionary
ABA in the late 1960s, helped bring professional
basketball back to Minnesota in 1990, and
fought the NBA to increase pensions for retired
players who played during the league’s early
years.
George Mikan passed away in 2005 at the age
of 80.
 The NCAA did not introduce a shot clock
into the men’s college game until 1985.
Women’s college games had been using a 30
second shot clock since 1970, but there was
a fear in men’s games that smaller college
teams would not be able to run and keep up
with the bigger schools.
Because of this, “killing the ball” was
a huge problem in men’s college basketball
for many years.
In 1973, a game between Tennessee and Temple
ended in an 11 to 6 score with fans throwing
ice onto the court in disgust.
Dean Smith, the legendary North Carolina coach
who coached Michael Jordan, James Worthy,
and many other greats, had a stall offense
he called the “four corners.”
Only 30 years later, in 1985, did they rectify
this by installing a 45 second shot clock.
In 1993, they reduced the shot clock to 35
seconds.
 In 1955, the same year Biasone brought
the 24 second shot clock to the NBA, the Syracuse
Nationals, coincidentally, won their first
and only NBA championship.
With Dolph Schayes leading the way, they defeated
the Fort Wayne Pistons four games to three.
Over the next eight seasons, the Syracuse
Nationals remained respectable and out lasted
many of the other smaller town teams in the
NBA.
By 1960, the Nats were the last remaining
old NBL team still playing in their original
city.
On March 26th, 1963, the Nats lost in overtime
to the Cincinnati Royals (formerly the Rochester
Royals) by the score of 131 to 127, knocking
them out of the playoffs.
That was the last professional basketball
game to be played in Syracuse.
That year, Biasone sold the team to an investment
group who promptly moved them to Philadelphia
before the start of the next season, renaming
the team the 76ers.